sylvain n'guessan analyse politique
directeur de l'institut de stratégie
d'abidjan bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france pour évoquer
cette situation en côte d'ivoire où on
dénombre donc deux mille personnes
contaminées mille guéri 27 personnes
décédées du cobp id est ce qu'on peut
dire que les pays africains ont échappé
au cas où ils font tout de même encore
rester très prudent selon vous je pense
qu'il faut rester très prudent bleu ou
mois une étude sud africaine qui a
démontré que la paire eur jpy qui
pourrait arriver au mois de septembre
donc disons encore quatre mois pour moi
je reste tranquille danoise elle est
respectée dans la mesure du possible la
deuxième barrière de sorte à ne pas
connaître les mois qui viennent
présenter moi j'ai eu dernièrement
concernant le cas du brésil pour les
plus grands alors tout même le bilan est
fort heureusement pour vous on est on
est très heureux pour la côte d'ivoire
or est plutôt modeste dans votre pays
comment l'expliquez est ce qu on peut
l'attribuer notamment une population
très jeune où il ya d'autres raisons
selon vous par un ensemble de facteurs
la voix quoi tu vois c'est un violent
aussi que ça peut clairement pas joue
donc c'est pas franchement un très grand
nombre
peut-être que si on était passé à 2003
mm un joueur est un peu plus alarmant ce
qui n'est pas le cas présentement
à côté de ça soit 7 % de la population a
moins de 30 ans donc mon
scientifiquement c'est pas encore ce
mois démontrer mais avec la jeunesse la
population on arrive quand même à
résister plus beau c'est qu'on a lu dans
ce test de milieux scientifiques lui
faut espérer que
le bernois race également ce qu'il a
fait puisque nous sommes en lui
adressant dépistage trois zones de
muscat reprennent le pouvoir a fait ce
qu'il pouvait dans cet ensemble de
facteurs qui fait que le chiffre aussi
bas en côte d'ivoire quels sont les
moyens dont vous disposez en côte
d'ivoire on sait que en europe beaucoup
de pays ont manqué c'est le cas de la
france de tests de masques notamment est
ce que vous êtes plutôt bien dotée à ce
qu'on voit là la cantine ne sont plus
les cas le 11 mars 2020 du rangement a
jusqu'au 25
dans les divers pays européens la chine
la france et qui a passé beaucoup de
commandants le dernier du sculptural au
public
il a dit par exemple que la 190
milliards ont déjà été alloués à la
lutte contre la pandémie le virus donc
débuter un but ici n'est présentement
les marchés à l'aïe à plusieurs masques
sont distribués dans les forces de
l'ordre des grands carrefours le pouvoir
fait ce qu'il peut comment vont soigner
les patients avec quels médicaments
parle souvent de ces traitements anti
paludisme en afrique est ce que c'est le
cas vous soigner dans les hôpitaux avec
ces médicaments dont notamment la
chloroquine à l'époque est en plein
débat qu'il a vu en france le pouvoir
ivoirien si j'ai bonne mémoire canal du
ministre de la santé avait c'était le
traitement par la commune qui ont parce
que comme vous le savez la côte d'ivoire
13 à l'idée reçue les recommandations de
l'institut pasteur dont je pense que
officiellement les autres ils sont pas
des marques et des recommandations de
l'institut pasteur mène à titre
individuel
10 manque entier le dictionnaire mort à
différentes vitesses et puis avoir eu
d'autres mesures d'accompagnement de
traitement de la pandémie du col roulé
sur le sec le pouvoir c'est beaucoup
aller mieux sur les recommandations de
l'institut pasteur
merci beaucoup sylvan n'guessan d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur arte france
pour nous avoir exposé la situation des
pays d'afrique et particulièrement celle
de votre pays la côte d'ivoire